The new season of Yellowstone has lots
of fans talking — and they don't have
good things to say! Here's why fans of the show
are fed up with this ongoing sibling rivalry.
Yellowstone fans have had some bleak opinions
about Season 5 of the show since it began airing
in November of 2022. Many loyal viewers
have begun to call the program out for its
repetitive storytelling tropes, which mainly
feature the Dutton clan suffering mightily,
then claiming rip-roaring revenge on their
enemies. Fans are annoyed, for instance,
with the fact that Kayce Dutton and his wife,
Monica are currently suffering through the
aftermath of a miscarriage, which feels like
an unnecessary trauma that doesn't do anything
to drive either character's stories forward
and just piles more misery onto their heads.
The storyline is one of a number of stories
that are feeling tiresome to some members of
the audience, according to many posts on social
media. At least one relationship on the show,
in particular, has begun to draw grumbles
from fans, who are getting awfully
exhausted from the endless conflict
between these two Dutton siblings.
Beth Dutton understandably holds a grudge
against her half-brother, Jamie. After all,
he's the reason why she can't have biological
children after he took her to a clinic on the
Broken Rock reservation after a teenage tryst with
Rip resulted in her pregnancy. She was sterilized
after an abortion was performed at Jamie's
request, and without her expressed consent.
Add on a heaping helping of sibling rivalry and
misplaced loyalties and you have a woman bent on
revenge. When Jamie shows up to bail Beth out of
jail during the fourth episode of season five, she
realizes he's been caring for the child he shares
with his ex-campaign manager. Thus, Beth vows to
take the kid from Jamie just to rob him of the
pleasure of parenthood that she has been denied.
But fans of Yellowstone are getting sick of Beth's
vendetta, no matter how understandable it is,
as Jamie has shown remorse for his horrible
deed. On Twitter, many fans are both exhausted
by the storyline and the character's
treatment of each other. One user wrote:
"Next time you see him you can kiss him
goodbye because he's as good as gone."
Another Twitter user even called it the
most irritating part of the program.
Some fans who are sick of the sibling
rivalry storyline think it would help
if Jamie worked up some courage around his
sister. One Yellowstone watcher tweeted:
On the Yellowstone subreddit, the opinions from
fans weren't much better. One redditor wrote:
Another redditor had an idea for how to turn the
Beth-Jamie situation into something new
by bringing in a third party, writing,
This would undoubtedly change
the dynamic of the storyline,
but it could have drastic repercussions for all
three characters, especially Jamie. Some viewers
took a different route and offered up other
storylines that the series should introduce
to get away from all this repetitive Beth-Jamie
nonsense. One person suggested on reddit:
They'll have to keep watching
to see how it all pans out.
Yellowstone Season 5 is currently
airing on the Paramount Network.